scientists are at war with kovat 19
dozens of laboratories are now
battlegrounds in the race for a vaccine
here at Oxford University
volunteers blood samples are prepared
for testing ahead of the first human
trials of a vaccine the blood will be
checked for antibodies and any t-cell
response to the virus t-cells can
recognize and destroy infected cells
and here in Germany one small company
part funded by Microsoft billionaire
Bill Gates says it too will soon have a
vaccine ready for human trials it may
look like slow work but things are
moving at breakneck speed it can take
decades to develop a vaccine this lab
wants one not sooner people are saying
to 18 months which of course is much
much shorter than a normal development
for vaccines that can be 10 15 even 20
years this is the enemy
Korona means crown in Latin named
because of the spikes on the virus's
outer coat this crown is also its
weakness the vaccines under development
contain the genetic sequence of this
surface spike which Prime's the immune
system to attack the virus if it later
infects the body but what about those
most at risk of contracting the virus
symptoms can range from a runny nose to
a sore throat to a fever but it can
escalate quickly among people with
respiratory problems or underlying
health issues into full-blown pneumonia
one team of British scientist believes
our best line of defense lies deep in
our lungs they've developed this inhaler
to help restore levels of a substance
called interferon beta in people's lungs
vital for removing viruses from the body
unhealthy lungs lack interferon beta
levels also naturally deplete with age
which is why elderly people are more a
risk of contracting the virus patients
with lung disease diabetes pre-existing
heart and cardiovascular disease they
get the inhalation once a day for two
weeks to increase the viral immunity in
the lung to prevent the virus from
replicating and eliminating the virus
more effectively the virus has led to an
acceleration in engineering this rapid
kovat 19 test has been developed by the
German company Bosch blood samples are
inserted into the cartridge for analysis
it takes two and a half hours for a red
zone
and it's 95 percent accurate but it
could be many months before the
equipment's readily available meanwhile
a number of firms including the British
vacuum maker Dyson aeroplane maker
Airbus on the Formula One team McLaren
are now racing to develop breathing aids
to meet urgent demand no single company
or laboratory can do this alone
it requires international effort and
resources the world's best brains have
been mobilized our greatest hope lies in
science Nev Barker al-jazeera London